- Gary Vaynerchuk, one of the
co-founders of Empathy Wines,
and we are tasting the
new Empathy Wines 2019
with one of the individuals
that is so integral
to the success, this gentleman
right there, Mr. Tom Merwin.
Pretty excited about that,
he'll be joining us
shortly and some others
from the Empathy community.
If you are not part of the Empathy family,
empathywines.com right now, we would love
for you to join us.
Please become a club member
where you get a subscription
of our beautiful White,
our Red comes out in the fall,
and the Rose comes later,
we have a whole system.
You might have also seen yesterday
that we transacted on this business.
Empathy Wines was sold to
Constellation Brands yesterday,
you might have seen some of the headlines
and that is pretty exciting
for Johnny and Stu, Nora
and the rest of the team,
big transaction in my career
and we're really excited about that
and so the timing, this was
scheduled for quite a while,
the announcement schedule was very fluid
given the world we live in,
COVID this and the other thing.
So, really fun timing for me as well
from the business side
and from the wine side.
Dustin is here, Dustin, can you say hello?
- Hello.
- Hello, yes, Edgar, this
does sell in California,
but it's a direct to consumer
you can't get in the
stores and restaurants
so empathywines.com.
Dustin, how are you?
- Excellent.
- Good, do we have our guests lined up?
- Yup, Tom is ready to
roll, so is everyone else?
- Awesome, let's get Tom in here.
- Cool.
- Tom.
- How's it going?
- Cheers brother.
- Cheers, a celebratory cheers for you,
I guess, good timing.
- Double cheers for me, no question.
Why don't you tell
everybody about yourself?
as you know, and we're very grateful
to have the partnership with you,
one of the big factors in this project,
and I think you know this,
we've seen in the wine world
people come along start brands
with extremely super uber
famous or leveraged vineyards
and they're trying to siphon the leverage.
One of the reasons we started this
was we wanted to give
some of the best growers,
farmers that we loved
even a bigger platform,
you don't see a whole lot of people
doing stuff like this in our world
so I'm very humbled for you to be here
and really hope that the Empathy project
can help your business to be frank.
- Oh, totally,
so just a little bit of
background about myself,
I'm a seventh generation farmer
in the greater Sacramento region.
- Say that one more time.
- I'm a seventh generation farmer
outside and my niece will be the eighth
if she decides to be a farmer
in the greater Sacramento area.
And we've been farming
in the Clarksburg region,
which is an AVA, an
American Viticulture Area
for over a hundRed years.
So, I did something, you
probably have advised
many of your followers to
do a little over a year ago,
I direct messaged Empathy
Wines via Instagram
and said, "Hey, I love
what you guys are doing
"and if there is ever any way
"for me to be a part of this
brand in supplying grapes,
"Chardonnay, and Chenin blanc,
"I'd just love to be a part of it."
So, and now I'm here and you and your team
have done an excellent job
at doing something extremely
different in the wine industry.
- I appreciate that, let's
talk about that actually
'cause I know the majority of the people
that are watching here.
Team, don't worry, I'll go into like,
really breaking down the White,
Tom's grapes are very
involved in this White
and I'll let him speak about that,
but what you did with the DM
is actually extremely important
because I know I would argue
80% of this audience follows
is watching this right now
because they're more
of a business mindset,
they're not here to get wildly educated
on the breakdown of Empathy Wine.
So, this actually makes this session
even more exciting for me
because I think we can
help a lot of people,
which is really my true passion.
How long have you followed me?
And then, good.
- Just, I mean, for just
you, your personal brand,
probably five or six years.
- How old are you?
- I'm 37 years old.
- Right, so when I
started Wine Library TV,
you were seventh generation
so it was in the DNA,
but you didn't know of me when
I was doing Wine Library TV,
were you on YouTube at that time?
Did I hit-
- I had seen the videos,
but it hadn't really,
I mean, to be honest, my
passion for wine itself
hadn't clicked yet.
So, but once I did the research,
dug a little bit deeper,
somebody providing such valuable content
while all the while helping
their family business,
I felt a connection.
- It clicked, yeah,
that makes sense
- Yeah, totally.
- So, more recently on the business stuff,
some of the other stuff, da, da, da.
And so, literally, you DMed Empathy.
- Totally, I did that and
literally two minutes later,
I got a response back and
three or four days later,
I met with the winemaker
and then after that,
had your team come out,
visit the vineyards.
And this was before I even
sold you a ton of grapes
and started flying from there.
- And look at this, look at this,
John Troutman gave you a love.
He is the best.
- John's awesome, man.
When he called me, to let me know
about your guys' big news,
you could hear the excitement in his voice
and I was excited for him
and you guys, it's awesome.
- Dustin or John, Nate,
Nora, any of the characters
here on video with us?
- Nate, was in here, but
now he left. (chuckles)
- Was he just checking up on you
to make sure you knew what
the hell you're doing?
- Oh wait, I think he's back.
Nate, can you turn your video on?
And here we go.
- There he is, there's my
handsome partner in crime.
Nate, how are you.
- I'm doing well.
- Say what's up to Tom.
- Tom, how's it going?
- Doing great, it's July.
We're getting closer to harvest.
- How you feeling about
this vintage, Tom?.
- So, it's funny you mentioned that,
it's a dryer vintage
and for our wine region,
that's actually a good thing
so disease pressures are extremely low,
there's no issues at all
in the vineyards right now,
and with this drier climate,
that we're gonna have a harvest, I mean,
anything could change it's
farming, open air casino.
I think they were on
track to have a great,
especially for the Chenin
blanc and Chardonnay
that I grow for you guys,
I think it's gonna be an
awesome vintage, awesome.
Very concentrated, very
powerful and a lot of flavor.
- Oh, look at Trouty in the building,
John didn't wanna be left out.
- It's a party, I always wanna join.
- I think you wanted to join
'cause Tom was giving you huge accolades
and you wanted to get some extra love.
- It's funny when I'm being
critiqued, I can never be found.
- Yeah, in these business meetings
through the last decade, John,
when you've done a big problem,
all of a sudden weirdly you're on the cape
and like the service doesn't work
and we can't talk to you
for a week, but sure enough,
a single fucking complimented
and you're on screen within a second.
(all laughing)
- Sorry, what, what?
- Tom, tell everybody who's watching
to give you a little bit more love,
where your wines can be found,
where your wines, your grapes are in,
if you can disclose that or, you know,
obviously from a farming standpoint,
not everybody here can come and support,
but where can they support?
Besides, everybody's watching right now,
if you were not signed up for
Empathy, just so you know,
'cause they unsubscribed from
their Empathy subscription
and said, "Gary, great run,
"I was really just doing
this to support you,
"Now that you sold the company,"
and I replied, "No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no
"we have a lot of the back-end
numbers we have to hit
"for this to get really good,"
you want me to buy the jets,
I need you to double up your subscription.
so if you're confused right now
and you're on a three or a
six or even a 12 subscription,
I need you to bump, bump, bump.
If you love the wine,
if you buy wine anyway,
you buy wine anyway, at
20 bucks, then I want you,
if you don't buy wine,
you don't need to do that.
If you buy wine for gifts and
clients, by the way, Nate,
I don't know if you heard the story,
a real estate agent reached
out to me, John, you too,
a real estate agent reached out to me,
giving, you know, wider support,
but the 12 bottles subscription
started giving out the wines,
and one, one, like a business account
'cause they came to the office,
'cause the person was a
Gary V fan, saw the Empathy,
got the business and the
commission on the house supposedly,
the person made him a mistake,
he told me how much the commission was
and I said, "Look, I need 50% of that now
"and 88 subscriptions of Empathy."
- I'm gonna need that
name to follow up on.
- Yeah.
- So, Tom, I'm sorry to side road
'cause that's why I got
Ds and Fs in school.
how can people support you?
- Yeah, so, a lot you can
find my grapes directly
that I'm allowed to disclose
and I'm also a business partner
and founder of the company
at fellowwines.com.
So, it's a 100% coursework AVA brand,
founded by myself and two friends
and trying to aspire to
hit half-year target so.
- We appreciate that.
Talk to us about the vineyard and John,
obviously we're very close
to this one on the White,
like, let's talk about what's in here.
- Yeah, so 50% of the
blend is Chenin blanc,
which Tom provided for us.
- Thank you, Troy Hooper,
just bought all three
pack, I enjoyed that.
If anybody orders right now,
claim it, we'll triple check.
We'll give you a shout out,
but if we double check and
you're not in the system,
we're gonna shame you,
shame you in perpetuity.
And Nate is looking at
the back end right now
so I'm typing,
so he's gonna look for
orders to come in here.
Empathywines.com, let's do that.
Okay, go ahead, Johnny.
- So yeah, 50% of the
blend is Chenin blanc,
which Tom, is that fair to say
that Clarksburg is kinda
holds his hat a lot
on Chenin blanc on the
White side of things?
- Totally, if you talk to sommeliers
from around the world,
they would say that,
outside of the Loire region of France,
Clarksburg is one of
the premier wine regions
in the world for Chenin blanc
and if you go look up some
old Wine Library episodes,
you know, Gary talks a
lot about Chenin blanc so.
- A fan.
- Yup.
And then another 25% of
the blend of Chardonnay,
which Tom also supplies for us,
just gives it a little bit
about weight and texture
that I think a lot of people
like in their white wines,
even if they don't know that they do.
And then the other 25% being Viognier,
which we get from Bokisch
over in Lodi not far away.
- And Nate, how do you
think about this wine
compaRed to last year's
White or in general,
I mean, obviously, all three
of us have been so deep
for almost nine months on this.
It's been a long time on
this Constellation deal,
how did you navigate giving
a shit about the wine
while working on the biggest transaction
of your business life?
- Tom, you like this?
I'm like grilling these guys
like I'm fucking CNBC or something.
- It's funny, throughout the process,
especially with everything
going on in the world,
which was a whole other
stressor for many reasons,
it felt like I had three
jobs, one was running Empathy,
one was working on the deal,
and then as the deal was getting closer,
it was kind of starting to
integrate with Constellation
while there was these other
things going on in the world
so it was extremely
stressful three months.
Yeah, extremely stressful three months.
- Nate, two years running
case member, Robert,
I mean, we need to, you know.
- we gotta give Robert a shout out.
- I like how Dustin puts up the comment
that says Moscato gets me girls,
Dustin, come on baby.
- They scroll up, so I had to-
- I know, listen, SFK is right,
Moscato gets him the girls I respect that.
- I know Robert,
I've seen that name for
the past couple of years
with a sport.
- Can you say thank you Nate, I mean.
(all laughing)
- I actually like it,
you're one of the few names
that is very familiar to me
so thank you for the support
since the very beginning.
- Thank you Robert so much,
Dustin, if we can get Robert on here
before this episode ends I'm into it.
- Cool.
- Figure it out.
- Yeah, so it was a
wild a few months, wild.
- Garrett Glenn, thank
you for just ordering.
Tom, what's exciting for
you right now in general?
Like, are you kind of really in it now?
you're such a cliche story,
like, seventh generation,
like, every generation from the second one
to the you, the seventh one
was like at 13, 14 being like,
I'm not gonna be in this
fucking bullshit wine business,
I'm gonna be a rock and
roll star, you know,
and then like you, is if
which happens quite often,
you realize, oh, wait a minute,
this is epic, it's
actually in your terroir,
it's in your DNA and then
that really fun moment starts
where you're like in that phase two, okay,
you got into it and now you're
kind of into it, into it,
or you kinda knowing your age
and just even thinking at
times, are you there right now?
- Oh, I'm there, I'm president
of our Clarksburg Wine Growers
and Vintners Association
so taking a leadership
role in our wine community
and for us, our end game isn't successful
as a personal farm,
it's more about getting the
Clarksburg wine name out there
and getting the public to recognize that,
hey, this is a great wine growing region
and we can do things that a lot of people
would assume we can't do with wine.
And as you guys have seen with our grapes.
- Trouty, what most took you aback
when you were tasting through
some of the components?
- So, I think I wanted
to really like the grape
and really like the juice
that he was supplying
'cause he reached out to us on Instagram.
And so, we have that deck
stacked against him or that form,
but I think with the Chenin in general,
the wines are just super, super
delicious, tons of acidity,
and yet they have a lot of complexity,
a lot of fruit, juicy,
and then the Chardonnay,
I think dollar for dollar
is just incRedible.
When you compare that
to a lot of Chardonnay
from down in Sonoma or what
it might be dollar for dollar,
it's incRedible.
- Looking at the time, Tom,
what website can people find you?
What's the best plug we can give you
before we bounce you out of
here and your beautiful face,
- The best plug would be
visit fellowwines.com,
and that would be it.
- This is right, if you're looking at it?
- That's right, that is exactly right.
- Everybody check that out.
Tom, thank you for being a
part of this story, really.
- Thank you, excited for
you, congratulations.
- Thank you, brother, if
I can be a help to you,
these guys have, like, it's
just Gary at VaynerMedia.
Thank you, awesome.
- Thank you, thank you.
Have a good one.
- hey, John, Nate,
I know we weren't planning
on having you here,
but I really enjoy razzing and joking
and buddying with you guys.
- I'll stick around to be razzed.
I'm gonna buy some wine
from Fellow Wine right now though.
- That's very nice, all right.
Let's move into our first guests, Dustin.
We have some wine questions.
- Hey, Gary, how's it going?
- I mean, Nate, do you
go by Nate or Nathaniel
or what do you go by?
- You can call me Nat.
- You can go by Nat,
awesome, Nat, real pleasure.
Say hello to John and Nate.
- John and Nate, what's up, how you doing?
- So damn good.
- Congrats everybody, huge news yesterday.
- Thank you
- thank you, thank you.
- Brand like Constellation
even with Corona in the
portfolio that's awesome, man.
So, good stuff.
- Thank you.
- So, one thing I was curious about is,
year to year, how do you decide
how much of each grape
goes into each blend
and from year to year, what
determines the variation
of change that you've put into that?
- So, this is a farming product
and obviously since I had a
lot to do with the architecture
of the concept, I wanted to
call it Red White and Rose,
actually, this is fun,
let's get under the hood.
Trout, you're really deep in it.
Nate's a real good wine guy,
but like, you're a better
wine guy than Nate.
Let's just get, you know.
- Let's call a spade a spade.
- Yeah, let's call a spade a spade.
When I kind of like, pitched the concept
of we're gonna make a Red, white, a Rose,
did you worry about that?
Did that land with you right away?
You know, Nat, my thought
was it's a farming product,
we own a vineyard, we're
gonna use my leverage,
my relationships, my
gravitas, serendipity,
like we just had with Tom
to find the best vineyards,
the best farmers,
and if one year the Red is 100% Pinot noir
because it's the greatest
Pinot noir vintage
in California history, cool,
if the next year it's a blend,
I thought that would be
fun, it would keep it fresh.
But, Trout, Nate, John excuse me.
Dustin, can you please change John's name
to Trout or Trouty.
- You're John.
- Like, John.
Anyway, Trout, did that land with you
or were you more like,
do you like it even now?
Like, where were you at with that concept?
- So, probably the first
24 hours or 48 hours
that you pitched me on the
idea, I didn't like it.
And it's probably because-
- Yeah, by the way, this
is the story of my life.
Doesn't like it and then now look,
Trout's like buying limousines.
- Go ahead Trout.
- Sorry, what, the audio.
(all laughing)
No, I didn't like it probably
'cause I was blinded by
being so in the wine world
where everything is about
the single grape variety
where it has to go by the certain rules
and then probably the
marketer and brand guy
and me kicked in after
sleeping on it for a day or two
and I realized let's just
make the best wine possible
for the best money and that
might change year over year.
- So, Nat, what goes into that
when you create that kind of flexibility
is stuff that you know
that I like in business,
which is of the moment.
I'm not locked in to being a Merlot.
I'm not locked in to being
a Rose made from Pinot noir.
I'm not locked into being a Chardonnay.
My obsession is that
everybody who subscribes to it
gets the best $20 wine,
then I need as much
flexibility on that as possible
so we're out there tasting,
making relationships and honestly,
that's why we did the
Constellation transaction.
That puts us in the stratosphere,
if all of you thought it was good now,
wait to see what we've
got cooking at 20 bucks.
I mean, people are gonna crap their pants.
I would have said shit,
but now within the Constellation world,
I'm not sure what I'm
about to say with that
but it's gonna be a big deal.
- Yeah, and speaking of changing,
obviously, there's a lot of changing
in the business world going on right now,
what did you do to adjust
the pandemic, obviously,
like I'm somebody-
- Real quick,
I apologize, Jennifer, yes.
Did he just say Rose made from Pinot noir?
Roses are made from red grapes
so it's the skin so like, yes,
that exactly what I said, Jennifer Dolten.
Go ahead, Nat, talking
about navigating corona.
- Yeah, sure, so like, I'm sitting at home
drinking more than I was before,
like, what have you done
to reach more people,
you could say that's
probably helped with sales.
Where do you see opportunity also,
Like I'm a sales guy, actually,
the first time, Gary,
I ever got to know you
was, I worked for the Yankees
and you came and spoke-
- Oh and I came and spoke
in that little group?
- Yup, yup.
- How did group like that?
Cause I came in hot.
- So you know what, it was
great, you were fantastic
'cause a lot of the things you were saying
are the things that I
raz on my bosses about,
and I'm just like, can you listen to Gary?
Like, this dude's more
successful than you.
- And so, was it two groups after I left?
Like, the youngsters were like, yeah,
and some of the old guard
was like, fuck that guy?
- It will, some of it's
just like, yeah, you know,
we hit the manager's like, yeah, you know,
we have our process, but then like,
but then a lot of the
other people are like,
come on, man, you gotta be flexible,
you gotta go with the time,
but the Yankees are run by the old guard
but at the same time, we do such and said,
there's such a big brand behind it
'cause there's a lot of different things
you gotta go into with it.
- Of course.
- But yeah, so also, where
do you see, obviously,
alcohol's something you
can sell a lot more now,
where do you see other sales opportunities
in the business world growing
over the next six to 12 months?
- Home offices, technology
and other things
that play towards home offices,
everybody is gonna have a
bigger balance of work from home
than pre-corona whenever
we get back to normal.
So, I would go there.
- Yeah, that's definitely
a good move, yeah.
Sport sales is a little rocky right now,
so always looking for some business advice
- Nat, thank you so much for being on.
- Appreciate your time, Nat, take care.
- Can I give a couple shout outs here?
- You can, Nate, Jeff, looking sharp
and we'll be with you in
one minute, go head Nate.
- Hey Jeff, real quick for
the new Empathy subscribers,
Paul Rubin, Aim seltzer, Craig Ernst,
Paul Bonakowski and Karen Wessling.
- Love it, Dustin, I have
no idea why empathywines.com
is not down here, I have
no idea what you're doing.
- All right, hold on a second.
- All right, Jeff Green.
- How you doing?
I'm Jeff Green, I'm a wine director,
general manager of a program
up here in Newburgh, New York
up in the Hudson Valley and
currently running a program,
we've gotten the Wine
Spectator Best of Award
four years in a row.
We are currently set
to open another restaurant
on the property,
a little bit smaller,
obviously with restrictions as well
with what we're all currently working in,
but our concept has
always been about value.
We wanna under promise and over deliver,
and when it comes to wine,
wine has been a huge part of our brand.
In fact, most of the reason
why people probably decide,
besides the food and ambiance,
but the wine list that we have.
And putting together this new concept,
we were looking to give
everybody certain varietals
or vintages from areas that
they might be renowned for,
but might not be able to afford,
but we were finding small producers
that might be on the same land,
or it might be able to be declassified,
but still great quality.
And what we've noticed is speaking
with a lot of our purveyors directly,
they're all expecting a lot of tariffs
to becoming in the near
future in different stages,
which is gonna really hurt
that whole value perception
for us of the European imports.
So, what I was asking is for your opinion,
do you think that with
these terrorists coming in,
because we had a concierge
on our reserve system
that I could get at $15 a bottle,
and now it's gonna go up to
23 and probably even more.
- My dad's dealing with
that at Wine Library.
It's gonna lead for you to
start looking at regions
like Quince and Terrain
and this is gonna hurt the upper echelon,
this is gonna hurt that 25 to $30 range
of French and German wines,
Because to your point, you, my dad,
they're gonna walk away from Sancerre
and they're gonna start looking at Terrain
and it's just going to
change the dynamics,
and some of those categories
are gonna be strong enough
to become a new echelon.
People are gonna start buying
35, $40 Sancerre at retail,
$100 Sancerre at restaurant
and yeah, I mean, the tariffs
are gonna change the game.
- So, what my thought was too,
is that perhaps this might
sway their perception value
in domestic wines where-
- Or notice that I didn't say yes, yes,
or it's gonna allow things to emerge.
To your point, listen, I
actually have to figure out
how to do some Wine Library TV.
Literally in the prime of Wine library TV,
I was so anti-California
Chardonnay and even more,
I didn't even think there
should be any Sauvignon blanc
in any of California, like none.
Over the last 10 years,
my palate's changed.
- Yeah.
- And I can't believe
how much I like certain
California Sauvignon blanc.
- Yeah, well I think a lot
of the producers out there
really started realizing that,
they don't want both bombs anymore,
they don't want the buttery feeling,
they want a little more lively acid
and then the ones that are on top
realize they had to make the
adjustment in the wine making.
- And that's what I was
screaming aback back then
and it's courtesy.
I mean, listen, it was
definitely not just me,
but at the time I did have a voice
and I think it's a better
wine because of it.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Awesome, well, Jeff, thank you so much.
- Yeah, pleasure to be on.
- Continue success, thank you.
- Thank you.
- I like Jeff, Nate and Trouty.
Trout, Jeff looks like your hero, like,
suit and tie, wine program.
- My guy.
- Nate's your guy.
I feel like I ruined you, you
were like a nice proper man,
then you volunteered.
Trout, tell everybody, listen to this,
'cause I think this is something
that I'm sure a lot of
people who follow me,
I'm gonna get the emails and
DMs dream it up this way.
Like, what was the first
human interaction we ever had?
- The Boston Wine Expo in 2008,
came and volunteered, handing out DVDs
back in the good old days,
Wine Library TV DVDs to people
who are coming by this trade
booth and tasting wines
and basically, just put in
free work for a couple hours
by doing free work and then
they asked, made my pitch.
- Trout, I remember obviously that event
'cause Kay Murph was there
and she worked at Wine
Library for four or five years
and is in the wine business,
750 ML probably killing it.
She's the best human.
Do you remember anything that stands out?
I've never asked you this,
we're like friends now,
we've worked together for a long time.
You know, obviously watch
me on YouTube videos,
did anything stand out for
that first day of that?
- Just being nice, honestly,
like I think it's funny,
not that I was star struck
'cause at that time,
you didn't nearly have
the following you had,
but I was definitely intimidated.
And everybody that worked for
you and everybody around there
was just super nice and like,
asked me about my background,
why I came there that day?
Why I was hanging out with them?
Which honestly is probably
what kept me working for you
for so long and say you surrounded
yourself by nice people,
really smart people, but nice people too.
- It's cool, all right,
let's keep it going.
Who was at the Boston Wine Expo with us?
- Brandon, Matt Sinema, K. Murph.
I don't think Ian Dorn was there,
but I got to know him later too.
- Devin, what's good?
- Hey, what's going on, man?
first off, man, I'm super hype
to just be even on this
stream, which I'm not even sure
if you actually remember
me but I know we met
and I know you were just
talking about with John there
when you guys met, like, so you and I,
we actually met for the first time
at CES back in January this year,
and we talked for a little while
and you were saying about how,
you were talking about just
basically about your business
and everything like that
and what you got going.
And it was funny because one
of the things with myself
is we were talking and it was
funny because I kept saying,
"Man, what if I ran into
Gary here while I'm here?"
And funny thing about it,
that's exactly what happened
and then right after
that, I tweeted it out
and you eventually were saying,
I think Casey had retweeted it,
and you were basically saying
that I could come out there
get my 30 minutes with you in New York,
which was super dope by the way,
I do want to tell you that,
I appreciate that, man,
for you being a part of
that and saying that.
But anyway, first off before
I get into my question, man,
I do wanna give a major
shout out to you all
as far as what you guys are doing,
the new acquiring, what
you guys has have, man,
I think is super, super dope
so a major shout out to you
guys with that for sure, man.
- Thank you so much, what
can I answer for you.
- Now, one of the questions that I have,
like me, I run a tech
channel here on YouTube
called CK Tech and one of the things
that I have to ask you guys
about in regards to tech,
how would you say that
tech actually plays a role
within the wine industry in itself?
- John, Nate, Nate, maybe
you can take this one,
You play a lot in this game.
- Yeah, so tech is
interesting in the wine world,
I would say, because it is
a very regulated business,
especially going direct to consumer,
you have to play within the guidelines
that are at a state by state level.
There's more out of the box
solutions for the wine business
that can kind of help you
build your eCommerce platform
for a direct to consumer business.
We did it a little bit differently,
we kept the customer in mind first.
We wanted to make the most
customer centric experience
in our website possible,
we want it to have as
frictionless buying as possible
so we built our website
on top of Shopify Plus,
and then work backwards from there
of what do we need to build into this
to make it compliant and make it work
in this regulated industry?
So, it's been a pretty complex process
over the past couple years,
but tech was kind of at the forefront
of how we scaled this business.
- And then obviously from the tech stack,
just obviously, using modern communication
to build the brand, I
mean, this is a wine brand
that sold 15,000 cases in it's first year
and was all done on
social, so there's that,
and then there's in the
macro wine business,
when I was a kid, there
was bad years with wine
and now because of the weather technology
and the technology in winemaking,
I mean, California makes
good wine every year.
And like, literally back,
literally I remember
as a kid being scared,
I'm like, ooh, what if you bought it,
you know, not knowing shit
being like, oh, you
could buy bad wine, bad,
doesn't taste good at all.
Now, people might not like something,
but it's not a flawed wine, it
doesn't have insect disease,
it doesn't have weather issues,
it doesn't have water issues
and so that's been a huge game
changer in the wine world,
the technology of weather
and farming and winemaking
and the advancements in technology,
even in my short life are extraordinary.
- Okay, do you attest like, as
far as social media to that.
As far as the growth on how you guys
were able to scale your
business to the level
of where it's at?
- Only, only.
- Okay.
- I mean, literally,
I think the only thing we
did was I was on Fallon.
Other than that, everything was social,
- (chuckles) okay.
- we did a little tiny bit of press.
The people we worked with
are my favorite people in it,
but traditional PR, and that
was actually really fun,
Devin, thank you so much for being on bro.
Anytime, just hit me at any time.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, for sure.
- Appreciate you.
- Yeah, yeah, for sure.
- Nate, Trout-
- Appreciate you.
- Thank you.
- Nate, Trout, I think you
guys probably realize this,
one of the more fun things,
actually talk about this,
this might help a lot of people.
You were important cogs
in the Vayner machine,
ultimately ending up in a role
called the office of the CEO
four person team with
incredible Maribel Lara
who's a huge executive of the Sasha group,
Marcus Krosastik, who is my chief of staff
and then you were part of that team.
Nate, you obviously
worked very close to AJ.
Trout, we worked a ton together,
You learned a lot from Kelly McCarthy,
other things you've
been around for a while.
What was the biggest difference
between being a key cog in a machine
to then being actually a
partner in the actual business?
- John, you want me to go?
- You take it away.
- I mean, it's a whole
different mentality.
It's your business and things matter
like they didn't before
you had a support system.
Before you had a support system
of VaynerMedia when I started there was 30
and I think when we left
it was around 700 people
so the last two or three years,
there was a big support system around you
where if something was going wrong,
there was teams and infrastructure there
to fix problems and leaders
of different divisions.
Me and John were leading
this business from day one
and thankfully we hired
a lot of really great,
smart, hardworking people to
help us through the challenges,
but at the end of the day,
it's like, the buck
kind of stopped with us.
I think Gary did an awesome job
letting us run the business
from a day to day standpoint,
and having us use him
when needed, but allowed,
he gave us that freedom
to run the business.
So it was being an entrepreneur,
it's just very different
than working in a system.
And I think entrepreneurship is difficult.
I think that's what I learned
in the first six months
of it's not a-
- Would you argue
that you had a far greater
appreciation for my abilities?
- Yeah, of course, and
I was so close to you
from a day to day standpoint
so it looked normal.
When I was your assistant 10 years ago,
that's kinda what I came into
and that looked like just
what normal life was,
but then when you actually
have to make the decisions
and you're running the business,
it's a very different feeling.
- Trout.
- I mean,
Nate kinda summed it up, but
maybe another way to say it is
every single problem is your problem,
like, if it's an HR issue,
if it's a finance issue,
whatever it is, especially
when it's a small team
of only a handful of people,
you're kind of dealing with everything.
Whereas at a big company,
when you're a cog
in the system, at the end of the day,
you can always go to somebody
else for help and support
or go to the CFO or whoever it is
and finances their
problem or the head of HR,
they deal with that.
When it's your business,
everything kind of falls
on you to figure out.
- And I would say, me and John
have been best of friends for years,
and so I would say that being
able to work on these problems
and solutions together
was definitely a benefit.
- Was it hard in the times
where one of you felt the
other person was the issue?
I mean me and AJ, this
relationship is different
post VaynerMedia to pre, not worse,
didn't get fucked up, but different.
it's just the real life of it.
There's no way that your
relationship's not different,
was that challenging at first?
Like John, the first
night you went to sleep
and be like, it's fucking Nate's fault,
like, how did you go through that
when you had this great relationship
growing up in a company together
where you did have a leader like me,
that really ultimately did
take on all the pressure.
So now, what you men are
talking about is pressure,
how is that to navigate when
you had to go through that?
- You know what's funny is probably things
that would have taken 60 days or 90 days
to like fester before they
would've gotten addressed
by normal business partners
happen instead in like five days.
Because, you just felt
uncomfortable enough
to be like, and there are
only a handful of times
where I think we actually
have like real conversations
we're like, I don't agree with that,
and it's because we've been
come up in the same system
where generally we see eye
to eye on most things but-
- Fair enough.
- Would you say the same Nate?
Then you go like, nah.
- Nate texted me more,
Nate texted me way more.
It's like, it's Trout, I'm
telling you, it's fucking Trout.
(all laughing)
- I would agree, I would say,
to get really into it though,
John and I are best of friends,
but since running a business together-
- By the way, Stu, who leads creative
at Empathy pretty much puts
the hammer down in that record.
Go ahead, Nate.
- I was just gonna say,
I do think our relationship
changed slightly
over the past couple of years
'cause every single day at work is
us together non-stop
building this business.
- Right, where when you were with me,
I had you guys dividing
and conquering at times,
of course cross, but now, right,
you didn't wanna see his
face after that night.
- I have a lot of traveling in my life.
- All right let's go to another question,
we got some people here,
I could have fun with you guys all night.
- Hi, Gary, Nate and
John, how are you doing?
- We're well, Stewart.
- Hey, so first of all,
as you've probably heard
a million times now,
congratulations on the Constellation deal,
that is a huge, I mean, that's huge
when it comes to accomplishing the mission
that you guys are trying to accomplish
with basically making
the best wine available
at the greatest price possible.
So, thank you very much for
contributing to that mission.
I'm the owner of the Wine
on the Dine YouTube channel.
So Gary, Wine Library TV
has been a huge influence
on what I do 'cause what I normally do
is focus around that 15
and $20 and under mark
and try to do my best and tell people
what is good for the value
and pair it with the sink.
They need to pair it with the
sink sometimes in my opinion,
but I actually have a
question for all of you,
this question I've been dying to ask you.
So, I have this concept of
what I call a gateway wine,
which is almost like when
people talk about gateway drugs,
like if you tried once,
you can't give up on.
Well, there's a wine where you try
and for the first time you try,
you go, man, I really
wanna get deeper into it.
I wanna learn everything about it.
So, what were your
gateway wines that got you
into this industry?
- Nate.
- Mine was a Sea Smoke Pinot noir
from the Santa Barbara County.
It was the first one I
had where I was like, wow,
this is delicious, I wanna
learn more about this.
I forgot the vintage
but I remember I was at my friend's house.
His parents opened the bottle
and that was like the
time that it clicked.
- Love it. Trout?
- Yeah, I've probably
answered this question
a bunch of different ways in the past,
but the one that when
you asked that this time,
I was like, yeah, that was it.
Oyster Bay Sauvignon
Blanc from New Zealand.
And the reason being, it
was like the late '90s,
when all of a sudden, I
was like 18 years old,
I couldn't even drink at the time,
but all of a sudden at
my dad's restaurant,
people were like,
"Do you have a New
Zealand Sauvignon Blanc?"
And that was the one we had on the list,
and then anytime you pour it,
you knew what it was right away,
'cause it was just so distinct.
So, that's the wine for me
that sparked my curiosity.
- You know, for me,
it was actually really,
really, really interesting.
By the time that I tell you this story
about this wine happened,
I probably knew on memory,
the rating by the wine
spectator Robert Parker
and Stephen Tanzer of 10,000
wines off the top of my head.
Because I started reading about wine
and obsessing about
knowing it all at 15, 16,
and the wine I'm about to tell you
happened when I was 21 and 1/2,
I had a mossy 1993, Amaronnie at a tasting
and I tasted it and it tasted,
for the first half a year
to year of tasting wine,
it all just tasted like
white wine, red wine,
it tastes like wine.
All this stuff I read
for six years of my life,
if I was like, what are
they fucking talking about?
What's cranberry, I don't taste
cranberry, this is red wine
and it was the first time
I tasted a wine and said,
"Holy crap," I got so
emotional, I left the tasting
to go to the parking lot, went back in,
called my mom in my new
cell phone that I had
and said, "Mom," it's literally,
I'll never forget this,
"Mom, it's gonna be okay,"
because I have this great fear
that I was gonna know a lot
about wine, but not like it.
And if I didn't like it,
I could never really help my dad
do what I wanted to help him with.
So, I loved it 'cause I like Snickers bars
and Whactchamacallits
it and like chocolates,
and it was like candy milk chocolate,
not this like, high
coco count, fancy stuff.
That's good for your heart,
and you have one niblet.
It was like eat three
Kit-Kats in a sitting good
and it completely changed
the course of my career.
- That's awesome, yeah.
So, the other thing that I
wanted to spend a moment on
is because I focused so much on value
and maximizing the value per dollar
for when people are buying wines.
First of all, I think Empathy
is a great value per dollar
so the mission you guys are
doing, just stick with it,
as you said, changing the world so-
- Wait till you see what this, I mean,
you know the infrastructure
they have from grape,
I mean, I'm gonna try to charm somebody,
at To-Kalon vineyard to let
me put that into Empathy Red.
I'm on a mission in this partnership,
I wanna make a $70 wine for 20 bucks.
- That would be fantastic
and I would buy all of it.
But one of the things
that I wanted to ask is,
so what are some of the
things besides going D2C,
direct to consumer,
that you feel can also,
there's still some room
and I know you don't
wanna give away secrets
because you gotta protect yourself too,
but what are some things
that can be done overall
from an industry that will kind of-
- Good news, Stuart, I have loose lips.
So, I think you have to look
at certain other arenas.
Look what happened with Rose.
when I left and retiRed
from Wine Library TV
and Wine Library Operationally Daily,
Rose still wasn't selling at all.
- Yeah.
- And so we have to look at new places,
Clarksburg, Chenin blanc, right?
Maybe it's Idaho Semillon,
maybe it's Virginia Viognier,
maybe it's North Carolina Cabernet Franc,
maybe it's a blend of Zinn and Chardonnay.
I know I'm getting
completely ridiculous now,
maybe it's wine, maybe it's Sangria,
maybe the destiny of the wine business
is infused with actual fruit,
I don't know, innovation.
The end.
- Yeah, anybody else (laughs)?
- I wanna get some of the
people that have been waiting,
so we're gonna go, Stuart,
keep doing your thing, brother.
- Thank you very much.
- Bye-bye.
- Francesco Belafonte is awesome,
he's doing quotes and in
YouTube, it's awesome.
All right, Scott S.
- Hey Scott,
- Hey fellas.
- Cheers.
- Good to see yah, I personally,
I have a confession to make,
this is actually my last bottle of '18,
and you'll know why in a second,
because when I tell you I'm from Missouri,
you will understand why it is sitting
in a family member's
home right now, the '19.
So, I figured this was special
enough for the occasion
to a polish off my '18, still loving it,
and great job, 'grats, awesome to see,
and thanks for spending the
time this afternoon and evening.
So, hey, it was awesome
to see you mentioned it,
you mentioned earlier
when you were doing Wine
Library TV about Chardonnay,
and I went through the same thing.
And so, when I was
looking for other whites,
one of the ones you've
mentioned Semillonn,
that could be on the
desserty side sometimes,
but Viognier was one that I found
that it just didn't have the
butter in the oak and all that
and so I started drinking Viognier,
but it has been amazing
to me over the years,
how it really hasn't
blossomed any, I mean,
like for instance, my
wine store, which is huge,
they have two Viogniers literally like,
just outside the bathroom in the back.
I mean, that's it.
And it is amazing to me how
we don't see more Viognier,
I am wondering why is that?
Why do we not see,
that seems like it would be a good unique,
it can be dry, it can be sweet-
- 'Cause there's no Robert.
Let me explain what I mean by that.
Most of the premium wines
that matter in today's world,
were heralded by Robert
Parker over a 30-year period.
The most important wine
critic in modern times,
Napa Valley is Napa Valley on
the back of Robert Mondavi.
In a lot of ways,
I was pissed that my name
wasn't Robert Vaynerchuk,
when I was doing Wine Library TV,
'cause it would have made
that statement I just made
even better because there's no Robert
for Viognier, Scott, I promise you.
if I grew up in a family business
that planted only Viognier
and I caught the bug the way I did,
Viognier would be the most
popular grape in America.
- Love it.
- No Robert.
- So, any thoughts on how we could-
- Yes, here's my thought.
Take advantage of the fact
that nobody knows about it,
and keep buying it because
if everybody knows about it,
it's gonna get a lot more expensive.
- Okay, we got to switch subjects then,
I can talk about that but hey,
so one other thing I will
ask is I haven't checked,
this is actually the second
time we've had a chance to chat.
When you were doing the Club
Empathy back what, March,
when you were asking people
to sign up and doing the call,
you helped me with some
branding in my business,
immensely helpful, it's been
pretty good, it is in travel
so you can imagine what's
been happening post COVID,
but it's hugely helpful
and even got the chat with Nate and Trouty
back in what, that was in
about a year ago in LA,
but you, you add a little something
that might be more
important than meeting me,
you were doing an Entrepreneur
Magazine interview
and I had something at that event
and I was hoping I could get
five minutes of your time
to get a John Hancock on this sucker,
'cause I've been keeping
it in the bag for you
It's just screaming.
- It's gonna happen, Scott.
- It's just screaming for
a John Hancock right there.
- I'm ready brother, it will get done.
When this is all over.
Scott, thank you so much
for your support, brother.
Take care of yourself.
- Thanks guys,
- Thanks Scott.
- It's awesome.
- Let's keep it going.
- Hey guys, first of all, congratulations.
- Thank you.
- My question is I'm pretty new to wine,
probably really got
serious because of you,
bought Empathy last year
so thank you for that.
- Thank you.
- My question is I'm kinda more interested
in the professional side of it.
I'm taking the WSTT level one right now
and I'm eventually wanting
to mix various grapes
with Meade and make Piman
and try to start a business with that.
- Very cool.
- So, my question is how would
you know what value of wines
if you're new like I am to go out and buy
and try and try to see like that.
- Jacob, my advice in the wine world
is the same I give in business now is
you just gotta go out and try and taste.
So, the advice is actually just make sure
you try different things.
I could care less if you
go Gewurztraminer or Rioja,
or Tannat or Pinot Grigio,
I just care that you try
different things every time
to give you a shot to figure it out.
- Okay is there, would you
say, a price point then,
is I guess I'm getting at?
Like, kind of ignore the bottom
of the barrel wines and grape varieties
that you almost are guaranteed
that you are getting.
- I think Portugal is
insanely under-priced.
- Okay.
- John, Nate.
- I think my answer actually
is a little bit different
than yours, Gary, I think the tasting
is definitely a huge piece of it,
just tasting as much as you can
at all different types of price points.
Even if it means you've
tasted cheap bottle,
just to confirm you don't like it.
But knowing that you're
somewhat studying with WSET,
I did the same thing with
the Quartermaster sommeliers.
I actually oddly found that I learned more
just on the internet, just
going to internet wine forums
and talking to people
and it was totally free.
- You learned more from Wine Library TV.
- Yeah, Wine Library TV, yep so-
- Hey Jacob, real quick, I apologize,
You're starting to watch it, Jacob.
- Yes, I think I did finish
episode 24 actually before this.
- What's the biggest, you know,
I have not talked to a
human being who's this young
who's known me, got into wine
and now has got like any,
this is just good learnings for me,
I'm being selfish a little bit.
Any weird, and it's like,
when you watch the first 24 episodes,
are you like, oh, Gary's
changed or he's the same
or, oh, weird, he used to be like,
any weird insights that
I could learn from?
anything interesting?
- I wouldn't say weird,
like knowing that those
videos go back to 2006
and seeing how you act then
versus I've been following
you for probably five years.
- Wait till you get to episode
55, I'll save you the secret.
You hit me back after that, all right.
Yeah, anything to add to that?
- Nope.
- Alright Jacob, anything
we didn't touch on?
- No, that's pretty much it.
Appreciate it guys and congratulations.
- Thank you brother.
- Actually, Dustin, I
know that was gonna be it,
but let's sneak one more in.
- Gary V, what's going on (laughs)?
- What's up brother, say
what's up to Nate and trout.
- Hey what's up Nate and Trout,
I just got the chat messages,
I was getting kicked off.
Thank you for putting me on, man.
It is a pleasure to be
here and meet you guys.
- Pleasure.
- I just wanna say
congratulations to you all
on this huge accomplishment-
- Hey Tyler, real quick-
- Being acquired this insane deal.
Young entrepreneurs like
me, I'm 21 years old, yeah.
- Is that chest hair?
- (laughs) Yeah.
- Dude, that's some sexy shit, bro.
You're breathing.
I just wanted you to know,
keep going, keep going.
- I was just saying, you know,
as a young entrepreneur this is something,
and this another thing to
look up to, man, from you,
but going into my questions,
'cause I know you're limited on time.
So, when you were 14, what
really drew you towards wine?
And sparked this vision of
what you've now created here
with Empathy Wines?
- Nothing, I hated it.
My dad forced me to work
in the liquor store,
I was making $1000 dollars a
weekend selling baseball cards,
and now I have to work at the store,
two bucks an hour, bagging
ice, I didn't like alcohol,
I didn't drink a single thing
of alcohol in high school,
I wasn't attracted to that lifestyle,
but what attracted me was around 15, 16,
there was this thing
going on where I was like,
wait a minute, are these
rich people collecting wine?
And once it became collecting
and that was my love in sports cards,
it completely clicked for me,
like completely, completely clicked.
- Just put you right on the page?
- Yeah, I was just like
in the fucking game,
it was basically like
Frank Thomas, Bo Jackson,
Walter Payton became Opus One
Silver Oak Chateau Petrus,
and that was it and then it got cool,
and then the story I just told
about tasting it and tasting it,
and then five years later
it was all about it.
And so it was really cool.
- Okay, and so what's
been your favorite wine
you've helped create so far anyway?
I know you guys have big
projects coming up, I'm excited.
- I would say the Empathy White last year
because it was the place where
we had a very strong vision
for the Rose in the Red,
but the White, we kind of
went in kind of creatively.
And I don't know how you, John,
Nate, you guys remember it,
but I was really focused in that session,
'cause I was really like,
we have an opportunity here
to do something different, thoughts?
- Okay.
- The White last year,
we didn't have anything,
it was like a blank canvas,
which I think the Rose and the Red,
we kind of, it's funny
that we've partnered
with Constellation 'cause
The Prisoner was one
of the wines that we really looked up to
and wanted to produce a similar wine for.
But the White, we really
didn't have a comp
so going into it blind was
actually a fun experience.
I think how our Roses have
turned out, both of them,
have really become like
a red wine drinkers Rose,
which I think has hit a really
good spot in the market.
So, I'd probably say our first Rose,
I think it was awesome
to have a product in the market finally
after working on it for over a year
and to get that feedback
from so many different people
that they loved the Rose was awesome.
- Yup, I'm looking forward
to trying it, guys,
I'm ordering it right after this.
I didn't wanna miss my spot.
- Thank you so much,
man, have a great night.
- Cheers to you guys,
thanks for having me on.
- Hope everybody has a
great 4th of July weekend,
Nate, Trout, you guys
know how I feel about you,
which is that I feel you
should take all your money
that you made an Empathy and put it
into sports cards and I hope you do.
- You bought a big LeBron, right?
- Nate, I heard you bought a big LeBron,
people are gonna be like, Nate,
you're like, Nate's like family,
and real friends are going to be like,
Nate, so what did you do?
Like, what are you gonna
do with some of the money?
He's like, I bought a big LeBron.
- I bought my family a couple of gifts,
and the only thing that
I did was buy a Lebron.
- Proud of you, why are
you wearing a sweater?
It's the summer.
- It's a shirt.
- Okay, good, oh, it's
like a new age shirt.
- Yeah, it's a hip shirt.
- Trouty, Nate's changed post acquisition.
(all laughing)
I think he's really changed.
- I've got a lot more
grays is what's happened.
- Yeah, you've changed, Nate,
you've gone like, Euro
cool in two minutes.
I love you two so much and
I love you Vayner nation,
I hope you enjoyed this
hour across the board.
Big shout out to everybody
on all the platforms
that have been leaving wonderful
comments and I love you.
Have a great, great 4th of July.
Empathywines.com, we
would love to support,
we got a lot of wine to sell
so that Nate they can buy
more Euro shirts, see you.
- Bye everyone.